la scission ou la disparition du parti
socialiste je conseillerais de négocier
avec beaucoup beaucoup de fermeté et à
la fin de rompre de rompre parce que je
pense que si elle fit insiste pour
maintenir sa suprématie dans tout
le langage de voyous de certains d'entre
eux qui traite le président de la
république de bâtard c'est françois
rester et autres joyeusetés de ce genre
peut pas être enfant illégitime la
présence on ne peut pas négocier gül
batta on ne peut pas négocier avec la
france a souvent eu à négocier mais on
peut pas conclure donc à quel intérêt de
négocier négocier c'est pour rendre
clair aux yeux de l'opinion publique les
points sur lequel on est en désaccord
absolument irréconciliables les
socialistes sont en train de se
soumettre aujourd'hui à la france
n'allait pas je ne sais pas à l'heure où
nous parlons il ya un accord mais si moi
je pense qu'il faut négocier mais il
faut négocier avec une très grande
fermeté une très grande clarté
ceux qui étaient inégaux si non
négociable c'est tout ce qui remettrait
en cause la participation de la france à
gauche le patron aujourd'hui c'est qui
c'est jean luc mélenchon il y a
quelqu'un qui a eu beaucoup plus de voix
qui a plus de talent que les autres
j'aurais utinam comme dont 10 en latin
plutôt ciel que il aurait fallu que il y
ait dans la gauche sociale-démocrate
quelqu'un aussi talentueux que monsieur
mélenchon s'il y en avait un sas mais il
aurait fallu plus partis socialistes
fassent le travail formidable
café france à ce qu'on vise c'est à dire
de réfléchir un programme est de faire
un programme jeux pas d'accord avec nous
partie de ce programme est tous d'accord
est une grande partie de leur programme
et pas tous malheureusement pas avec
l'essentiel mais au moins ils ont fait
cet effort ils ont fait un programme néo
socialistes ont rien fait du tout été
depuis cinq ans ils payent le prix de
leur paresse et de leur vie anne hidalgo
c'est en 74 % à la présidentielle le
problème c'est l'incarnation c'est un
idée c'est la ligne c l'aps hausse il
aurait fallu je leur ai dit depuis le
début
dellal désistement de françois hollande
lancé des colloques des
tables rondes des réflexions par thème
pour reconstruire mais des faits chacun
du tout pas du tout que c'est une
défaite intellectuelle de la gauche
d'une démission intellectuelle de la
gauche le gouvernement qui n'a pas fait
le travail mais c'est pas nouveau
intellectuel de la gauche de
gouvernement c'est pour ça que pour ma
part j'ai fait a depuis ja
présidentielle avec une sorte de
d'entêtement tout piquer un peu
dérisoire j'ai fait des programmes
présidentiels à la cantonade mais si
vous le faites pas voilà je vous propose
un programme essaie d'en faire le ce que
vous ce que vous pouvez j'ai retrouvé
une partie de nos propositions à juste
titre dans la plupart des partis mais
mais les choses ne peut imiter comme ça
irait de justine blanchard et le coup
[Musique]